hey what's up guys I'm Kim PhD here and
it's 2014 everything leaks and this is
the second video making about the iPhone
6 this time with an exclusive part this
is the front glass from the iPhone 6
tell you closer look so a lot of you
guys will remember the last video I did
about the 4.7 inch iPhone 6 model which
a lot of you guys saw but this here
isn't a mock-up this is an actual
straight off the assembly line
iPhone 6 part from Apple and it's the
entire 4.7 inch front panel of glass
including a sheet of sapphire crystals
so this is important because of its
existence we can basically confirm that
yeah there will be an iPhone 6 with a
4.7 inch display and we now know that
this 4.7 inch model will have this
sapphire display not just Gorilla Glass
so there was some speculation that only
a larger 5.5 inch iPhone would get the
sapphire display but now we know that
rumors not true so what is so great
about sapphire crystal well it has a
number of advantages over Gorilla Glass
which like I said is on the front of the
iPhone 5s but the two main things you
need to know are that number one
sapphire is an extremely high quality
material and number two it is really
durable now I say high quality material
because this thing is paper-thin like
literally the same thickness as a sheet
of paper and it's perfectly see-through
I would say 0% opacity Apple already
actually uses sapphire in the iPhone 5s
on the camera lens and the home button
for this reason so the camera lens needs
to be super high quality material and
very durable and crystal clear to take
those great shots through it and the
home button also needs to be crystal
clear to be able to read your
fingerprint through the glass so again
it's sapphire so that would be the
number one thing I noticed just messing
around with this panel and holding it
looking through it putting it over my
eye basically you notice how little
distortion there is and how exact the
cover stay there's absolutely no color
shift while looking through the sapphire
glass now another thing I noticed while
cleaning it with a microfiber is this
particular panel seems really ok with
bending at least a little bit a little
bit of torque a little bit of flex a
little bit of give here and there and
I've never handled a similar 4.7 inch
gorilla glass panel but assuming this is
sapphire I got really curious about
exactly
how durable this is so I broke out a
knife and I broke out the keys and I did
some scratching or at least I thought I
was doing some scratching basically I
took the knife to the Sapphire pretty
hard I applied some deep pressure really
pushed it down and I got nothing so then
I moved on and I did it with my keys
again this is way beyond what you
normally do with the phone but I press
down really hard this is way past any
pressure that's going to be in your
pocket I scraped them drag them across
the panel apply a lot of pressure still
nothing
and then I went on to basically stab the
thing pretty hard right in the middle
and drag the point of the knife around
the surface with some serious pressure
again well beyond stuff you're ever
going to do with your phone and I got no
results so clearly you don't need a
screen protector here and lastly I tried
to bend it first
like seriously bend it so at first I was
kind of tentative because I thought
maybe there was a chance I might break
it
maybe shatter it but I slowly realized
there is absolutely no way I can break
this display under my own power there's
no chance I have a feeling I could drop
a rock on it but really I couldn't get
the surface to even scratch a little bit
at all the worst blemish on the surface
was actually my fingerprint marks and
the dust from handling it so much so
it's not attached to a phone with a
weight or anything so I couldn't do a
drop test or a corner impact test or any
of the important stuff to see if it
would shatter but from my experience and
from what I've tried it's almost
impossible to scratch this screen with
any regular use so that's really
exciting for this new iPhone I also have
you can see here the home button part
with the touch ID sensor which is the
exact same size as the iPhone 5s by the
way so this sapphire and the new 4.7
inch sapphire glass panel are pretty
much your best look at what we have on
the front of the iPhone 6 so far you can
really imagine what this new iPhone is
going to look like huge thanks to sunny
Dixon again for hooking up these parts
he's been super reliable in the past
with this Apple stuff so no hesitation
here and we have a better look than ever
at what the iPhone 6 is going to look
like really what I'm most excited for
even if it isn't any of the durability
stuff it's just how high-quality the
sapphire material is how clear it is I
think this is what they're going to make
a big deal about check it out it is just
about as good quality as a glass I'm
using two
accord this video I don't know if that
says much I don't know if that's
something that every front panel again
on any smartphone will do but it's
something to note this is an insanely
clear super high quality material and
I'm pumped for more phones at least
order to see the first phone to have a
sapphire front panel so anyway this has
been it thanks for watching this is the
front panel of the iPhone 6 feel free to
share this out and bed.this talk about
it wherever ask questions on Twitter if
you want to know more thanks for
watching I'll talk to you guys in the
next video peace